[Music]
[Applause]
boston globe senior nfl writer covering
the patriots host of the ben vollen
football hour saturdays from noon to one
on weei
and the uh great reporter covering the
new england patriots joins us on the
program how surprised were you with the
news yesterday morning ben
i'd love to pretend that i saw this all
coming but i can't i was very surprised
like everyone else
um for several reasons you know this is
a very veteran team that bill belichick
has built here veteran offensive line uh
playmakers the defense and they're
entrusting it all now to a rookie
quarterback i thought they were going to
start the season with with cam newton go
with the veteran i thought that'd be the
safer play
let cam kind of sink or swim on his own
and then if if he does sync you can turn
the team over to mack jones but i think
this is just a testament to how good
matt jones has looked throughout the
pre-season i think this is really about
him impressing bill belichick and the
coaches and showing that he's ready for
this not necessarily that he beat out
cam newton because i don't think that
cam had that bad of a preseason by any
stretch but i think that mac was the
future he's the guy they invested in and
he i think blew them away with his
improvement throughout the five weeks
the way he was able to build on one day
from the next his performance last week
in three practices where he was the only
quarterback running with the ones when
cam newton was out i think mack jones
took that opportunity and absolutely ran
with it
and then when you're gonna you know make
the decision to turn the team over to
your rookie quarterback and mac
i just think it wasn't tenable to have
cam newton around as the backup he's a
big personality when you watch practice
cam is the ring leader he's the guy
dancing during warm-ups and getting guys
hyped and guys definitely gravitate
around cam newton and this is mac jones
team now and cam's never had to take a
back seat to anyone before it's been
since 2008 when he was at florida that
he's been a backup so to me i i think
belichick made the right move just get
that element out of the locker room give
mac jones the space that he needs to
grow into the leader and clearly the
team thinks very highly of him do you
think cam asked for
to be released
i think it's probably mutual i don't
think cam wanted to be the backup here
he obviously
you know the writings on the wall he's
not going to get the job back from mac
jones unless there's an injury
and and i don't think the patriots like
i said i don't think they wanted that
dynamic in their locker room where
there's two quarterbacks trying to be
the leader and i don't know if cam can
turn the switch off he's just he's such
an alpha dominant personality he's
always used to being the guy
and i just don't think that's a good way
to support your young quarterback
nothing against cam i don't think it's
anything personal it's just who he is as
a person as a player and i think it's
going to affect his ability
assuming he wants a backup job we don't
even know he really wants to you know
not every quarterback who's made a
hundred million dollars wants to grind
it out as a backup for league minimum
so if he does want a backup job i think
just his big personality is going to
work against him with other teams the
way it did with the patriots
do you think that there is a seminal
moment where mac won this job that you
look back and you go
that's probably when he said or showed
to belichick and josh mcdaniels i'm your
quarterback
i mean i honestly think it has to be the
three days that cam newton
missed due to the quote misunderstanding
of the coven protocols whatever it was
you know cam not being vaccinated he had
to sit out for three days and of all
places to do it here in new england
where we all remember a guy named drew
bledsoe got hurt a kid named tom brady
came in and we never heard of drew
bledsoe again so matt got his
opportunity and i think he really ran
with it three days in a row 100 degree
practices he's out there grinding it out
doing a great job leading the team and i
just remember
multiple times in practice you know he's
leading a series on a two-minute drill
or what have you and he completes it
with a touchdown he comes off and he
gives a high five to josh mcdaniels bill
belichick's waiting for him with a high
five he's jumping in you know hip
bouncing against his teammates like he
could just see the confidence that he
had and that everyone had in him just
growing all around and so i think
absolutely that week uh just last week
where he had three days all to himself i
think that's when he showed the coaching
staff that he's ready for this you've
been covering this team i think for
close to a decade where would you rank
this move of all the moves that the
patriots have made
uh it's a big one uh
i i guess
i'm trying to think you know letting tom
brady go that was a pretty significant
one as well and one that there you know
i hope this mac jones for their sake i
hope it works out but but there's still
probably some doubts over whether they
should have let tom brady go
you know i guess you go back to the
lawyer malloy move where they caught him
on the eve of the season all the way
back in 2003.
this maybe doesn't rate quite as high
because cam isn't as entrenched with the
patriots as as lawyer malloy was but
this was definitely a big surprise maybe
logan menkens getting traded right on
the eve of the regular season in 2014.
that was a big shock to the system tom
brady was not pleased over that move as
well
but this is big i mean i don't think any
of us really expected uh bill belichick
to go with the rookie quarterback for
week one
belichick has coached
377 games with the patriots including
postseason exactly two of them have been
started by a rookie quarterback jacoby
brissette for two games in 2016. so this
is never belijk's never done this before
obviously he had tom brady for so long
but um you know i think this again is
just a sign that mac jones was really
impressive during training camp and i
mentioned this yesterday and of course
people jump all over me when i say it
that you know mac jones is you know he
he's tom brady
but his style is tom brady
not you know his resume and his destiny
and all of those things
it it felt like that you know josh
mcdaniels and bill belichick we're gonna
see
tom brady 2.0 like here's the next
reincarnation of it somebody who's
based their career on trying to be tom
brady like is it blasphemous to say that
mack jones
wants to be or plays like tom brady
well
yes because mack jones is still a rookie
i know but does he have the style though
ben oh no question okay
this is all about
going back to the tom brady style of
offense matt jones is not going to be
rushing for many first downs this year
they're not going to be calling read
option plays but mack jones can operate
from the pocket and he can deal the ball
from the pocket and that's what the nfl
is still all about you know athleticism
is is important for quarterbacks but an
immobile 43 year old quarterback with a
bum knee just won a super bowl because
he can operate from the pocket and so
absolutely this is a return of the old
style
um you know watching the patriots last
year was frustrating because cam just
wasn't delivering from the pocket eight
touchdown passes all season the passing
offense was a real grind uh his accuracy
was scatter shot all over the place now
with mac mac jones you've got a
downfield passing attack i think the
play-action passing game is going to be
a big part of their offense tight ends
down the middle johnny smith and hunter
henry um and and yes absolutely it is a
very similar style to what they ran with
tom brady especially from a decade ago
when they had gronk and aaron hernandez
as their two tight ends so i i
definitely think they're more
comfortable with mac jones and his style
of quarterback and in today's nfl you
got to be able to deal from the from the
pocket and i think matt jones is far
superior at that than cam newton was
i don't know how inspirational this
would sound to you if you're mac jones
but josh mcdaniel said
about mac jones he comes in well
prepared every day to do the things we
ask our guys to do he's generally taking
care of the football and giving the
other guys the opportunity to do their
job and make positive plays
wow that's that's uh
not exactly a ringing endorsement there
of your new starting quarterback what do
you make of josh mcdaniels uh assessment
yeah i don't know if we'll be splashing
that quote across the top of the boston
globe
um
you know that said i really see the
patriots coaches straining themselves to
not gush about mack jones i think it's
clear they love him and they're just
trying not to hype the kids okay and
that's why belichick named newton the
starter of the night they drafted um cam
newton they're just uh mack jones
they're just trying to keep a level head
about this thing and not get too ahead
of themselves but to me what what caught
my attention in the last couple weeks
with mack jones is not necessarily his
play on the field but the fact that
belichick in an interview was raving
about mac jones work ethic and then you
hear from respected veterans matthew
slater dante hightower brian hoyer
raving about mack jones and his work
ethic and how he's impressed the
veterans in hightower saying you know i
saw mack jones was studying our
defensive playbook and i've never really
seen that before and that you know he
just wanted to know what was going on in
that side of the ball so the fact that
um all these respected veterans and even
bill belichick himself have been very
impressed they can't help themselves at
times uh with mack jones and how um just
mature and he's been so far and his work
ethic so i you know mcdaniel's quote
there i just think he's really going out
of his way not to
you know build the hype with mack jones
but i think it's clear that they really
love this kid how big is that ticket now
in new england week four when the
patriots host tampa bay it might cost 11
billion dollars and in the stadium that
night i don't know i mean it was already
gonna be a huge ticket just from brady
coming back but yeah mac jones you know
it's like belichick's coming back to the
fight like oh you think you're you're
you're good brady like well i got my own
brady now i got brady 2.0 here so it's
going to be awesome i can't wait to see
how belichick defends brady you know
what kind of kitchen sink he's throwing
at him uh do they attack him with the
blitz up the middle do they play it safe
um to me you know the bucks are a team
that or tom brady
not always clicking on all cylinders
early in the season so i know they're
bringing back everyone from their super
bowl team but will they be operating
efficiently in that week four game when
they're coming to new england that is
gonna be just an all-time slug fest in
the regular season like i wish we could
just fast forward and get to week four
already
i'll leave you with this uh what is your
philosophy in asking bill belichick a
question in front of your peers
just uh dive in just go for it um
belichick
there's a misnomer that he hates the
media i think he absolutely enjoys his
press conferences and he respects the
media and i think he respects the media
that doesn't kowtow to him that is
actually going to ask him a tough
question and isn't afraid to go
toe-to-toe so i think you always want to
remain respectful and you don't want to
like
kind of ask him trolling leading
questions but there's no harm in asking
a tough question about cam newton's
vaccination status or you know any you
know what happened with aaron these are
real questions and you got to ask them
and i think belichick respects the
reporters who are willing to do that uh
seton do you have that uh question that
was asked this morning where bill just
gave a one-word answer
uh that i don't know if it's the first
one that is that on cam as a backup or
max starting and cam vaccination what
was the uh try that one and let me get
bill uh wondering how much did um having
those three days to himself for matt
jones help him uh beat out cam for that
position
yeah i don't know okay now that's ben
that's a fair question he's the only one
who knows
and he doesn't know
that that's my favorite stock answer
someone will ask him uh oh wow you gave
matthew judon 32 million guaranteed how
do you envision him fitting in the
defense i don't know you know like he
hasn't thought about
that he doesn't have a very specific
plan for matthew judon so could you
imagine how he would react ben if he
didn't like and respected the media as
as you're telling me
when he gives those gruff short answers
that means you've hit the nail on the
head
and so he's just trying to get through
it as quickly as possible
uh good to talk to you ben keep up the
great work thank you appreciate you dan
thank you that's ben bowlen the boston
globe senior nfl writer covering the
patriots